la signature récente de plusieurs
ententes de libre-échange suscite de
l'inquiétude chez bien des producteurs
laitiers
un peu partout au canada certains
cherchent donc à diversifier leurs
sources de revenus
en saskatchewan l'un d'eux à se créer un
engouement
étonnant pour son boeuf haut de gamme
[Musique]
le sud de la saskatchewan le grenier de
la planète avec ses chants de grandes
cultures qui s'étendent à l'infini
on y trouve aussi quelques fermes
laitières dont celles d'in et nico
crosby depuis 2012
il gère belby austin une ferme familiale
établie il y à presque 100 ans quand
j'étais jeune j'ai accompagné toujours
mon père à l'état pour moi c'était
évident que j'avais devenir producteur
laitier ya 160 vaches rousses qu'ils
produisent 6000 litres de lait par jour
[Musique]
dans les enclos à l'extérieur de
l'établissement aussi parmi les robes
style une centaine de bêtes noires que
les crosby élèves pour leur viande mais
pas n'importe quelle viande
je ne me contente plus de dire je suis
une grosse bûche produits du boeuf
maintenant je peux dire je suis in
crosby et je produis le meilleur boeuf
de toute la saskatchewan
depuis quelques années les crosby
cherchait à diversifier leurs sources de
revenus
les méthodes de production modernes
étant de plus en plus efficaces ils
constatent qu'ils n'ont plus besoin de
toutes leurs génisses roussety
[Musique]
on a optimisé notre production laitière
grâce à la génétique à la bonne gestion
il ya une meilleure alimentation
on a donc plus besoin d'autant de
génisses qui il ya 10 ou 20 ans on perd
de l'argent en continuant de les élever
il décide alors des six mines et
certaines de leurs austin avec de la
semence de boeuf angus l'étalon d'or de
la production bovine au pays
il réussit à vendre ainsi des dizaines
de vomir austin mis en bus au prix de
quelques centaines de dollars par animal
on a ici réussi à produire de la viande
d'excellente qualité équivalente du
triple à qu'on trouve en épicerie mais
je voulais me distinguer de la
compétition
[Musique]
en 2016 alors qu'il est dans un
restaurant de toronto
l'idée jaillit ce sera du boeuf wagyu
m'écouter 85 dollars n'était la première
bouchée j'ai compris que je goûtais
omeyer steak de ma vie c'est là que je
me suis dit c'est ce que je veux créer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les bovins wagyu originaire du japon
produisent l'une des viandes les plus
recherchés au monde
c'est bête développe persia j'ai trop
musculaire qui donne un goût
exceptionnel et une tendreté remarquable
à la viande
quelques fermes d'élevage voit le jour
au canada dans les années 90 la viande
qu'on y produit est souvent le résultat
du croisement entre les races radio et
angus in crosby fait le saut et achètent
de la semence de wagyu d'une ferme en
ontario il est simin quelques-unes de
ses routines les veaux ainsi croisées
sont élevées pendant quelques semaines
avec les veaux rostin de race pure
ils partagent des enclos jusqu'à l'âge
de 15 mois
les bovins croisés sont ensuite
transférés dans des enclos
d'engraissement
au bout de dix mois passés dans cet
enclos nos bêtes seront de la taille de
celle que vous voyez ici on espère à ce
stade avoir développer au maximum le
personnage de la viande comme le bon vin
plus on attend plus la complexité et les
gousses développe en 2018
les crosby font abattre leurs premiers
animaux
la qualité de la viande est exceptionnel
in décide d'appeler son produit le slow
beef ou boeuf des neiges le nonce mobile
fait une métaphore espérer du personnage
blanc de notre viande vive
c'est comme s'il neigeait sur lost et
c'est dans deux petits marchés locaux
qu'ils tentent de vendre sa viande ou
android market n'est dinally été payé
par la réaction de ses clients lorsque
yann m'a proposé son produit j'ai dit
allez on l'essaie on verra bien il n'y a
peu près pas fait promotion et tout
s'est envolé en une seule journée
pourtant le prix du produit est élevé
l'entrecôte par exemple se vend plus de
50 dollars la pièce soit le double d'une
coupe conventionnelle notre nom a
commencé à circuler de plus en plus
les restaurants locaux découvre son
boeuf
okon l'ust on à mousse dia le snobisme
teriyaki fait fureur
[Musique]
en peu de temps les grands de la
restauration s'y intéresse
[Musique]
cruijff kitchen origine à l un des
meilleurs restaurants de la province
son chef john à singstar burger est
membre de l'équipe nationale culinaire
du canada le goût est particulier en
raison du père sillage présent dans les
muscles
la saveur est prononcé délicieuse site
une viande très tendre qui nous pousse à
être créatifs nos coûts varient se sont
rares voiles yémen d'une journée à l'eau
ont fait du carpaccio on a aussi créé
une sorte de paix mis qu'un à partir du
grès de la viande de snober sécher
auquel on ajoute des fruits ça ressemble
à des rillettes
peu importe comment on servait le snober
les clients en redemandent et mais le
snow biche est une denrée rare
c'est que les crosby n'a battu qu'un
seul animal par mois notre prix de vente
est élevé parce que chaque animal nous
coûte cher on s'assure donc d'avoir des
débouchés pour notre produit dès le
départ
[Musique]
en octobre 2020 la filiale ce lobby
faisait crosby fait un pas de géant
il conclu une entente avec un
distributeur préau imite son directeur
général et si comme le souligne que la
demande pour la viande de boeuf haut de
gamme monte en flèche depuis 2016
les ventes de boeuf wagyu au canada ont
augmenté de 20% et on prévoit une autre
augmentation de 20% d'ici 2024
l'entrée coûte qu'on a maturé nous mêmes
trois mois de maturation autres la
qualité de la viande
sa popularité s'explique aussi par sa
valeur nutritive faible en cholestérol
est riche en acide oléique
l'alimentation change les gens réduisent
leur consommation de viande rouge est
lorsqu ils en mangent ils s'attendent à
vivre une expérience
[Musique]
les ventes de ce lobby ne représente
pour l'instant que pour cent des revenus
des crosby mais il compte dès 2022
doubler leur production de viande
j'ai de grands projets pour les cinq ou
dix prochaines années mais on verra où
le marché nous mènera en attendant il se
contente d'avoir atteint l'un de leur
grand objectif produire sur leur ferme
laitière l'une des meilleurs groupes de
boeuf au pays
mon plus beau compliment est venue de
quelqu'un qui m'a dit tu viens de gâchis
le steak pour moi je ne pourrai plus
jamais me contenter d'un autre système
que celui là
[Musique]